while the massive push to get nevadans
vaccinated continues there is a group of
people who
have some protection from it even
without the shot
denise valdez joining us live in studio
with the details in today's healthwatch
denise
so christian we're going to be talking
about people who've already had the
virus and their immune system produces
an antibody right
well a recent study looked at the
effectiveness of the covid19 vaccination
among people who either had the virus or
those who never got it
now the study was conducted on more than
52 000 fairly young
and healthy employees at the cleveland
clinic in ohio but
barely five percent of those had had the
virus so it's a really small sample
still though
there was not a single incidence of
reinfection observed in previously
infected people
whether they got the vaccine or whether
they didn't the trouble is
how long does that protection last will
dr karin deuce is an immunologist at
toro university
you don't really know ahead of time how
you're going to react
and you also don't know how well your
immune system
is going to process all of that
information from the virus
and generate a memory response
meaning you could have antibodies
protecting you from reinfection for two
months six months
a year it's really gonna vary quite
widely
so whether you've had the virus or not
medical experts urge you to get
vaccinated so just because you got the
virus doesn't mean you can't
get reinfected you can so it's very
important to get that vaccine
kirsten